le président madame la ministre à bercy
quand il faut l'on sait être pragmatique
à l'occasion de la fusion entre fiat et
le groupe psa l'état actionnaire a
indiqué le chemin de l'efficacité en
soit en choisissant comme siège social
amsterdam
il faut dire que c'est pas nouveau ça
s'est fait dans le passé pour renault
nissan
ça c'est fait pour airbus et pour
quelques groupes privés non croyez que
ce ton était révolue alors il faut
reconnaître que l'on peut être séduit
par la fiscalité sur les sociétés
les grandes sociétés aux pays bas on
peut être séduit également par la
stabilité fiscale
et puis l'état néerlandais utilisent
l'aéroport comme un point d'attraction
pour les grandes entreprises
internationales pendant le même temps le
patron de tesla devait choisir
l'implantation de son usine en europe
il a choisi berlin il a choisi berlin
parce que nous avions plusieurs sites à
proposer
vous pouvez proposer cinq clés pour les
ingénieurs mais de trouver qu'à berlin
il y avait des ingénieurs il y avait un
problème de foncier vous pouvez avoir
lampre-isd adp mais il a préféré berlin
il ya un aéroport publique de la russie
qui est un outil industriel et parle du
futur un report mais surtout c'était la
faisabilité de faire vite pour
construire vite
alors je voudrais savoir qui est bercy
s'occuper de traiter ces deux grands
industriels parce que l'investissement
d'un côté c'était 4 milliards avec entre
5000 et 8000 emplois pour tesla
j'ai oublié de vous dire qu'il y à un
fabricant japonais de batteries qui
vient investi quelques semaines avant
deux mineurs à berlin je voulais savoir
qui à bercy s'occuper de ça ou au
gouvernement pour faire en sorte que la
france reste attractive
[Applaudissements]